Laura, you're never going to guess what I found.
>> What is it?
>> Well I've, I've found my parents' genomes.
>> Really, what does it say?
>> Well I've been comparing them here for a little
while, but it seems pretty obvious that I'm an equal
mix of my parents. They each gave me half of
their genome, so I could have a whole genome myself.
>> Well but yeah, that's how it works. Like, all
the parents pass down half the genome to all the siblings.
>> Well, this is true. But it's not the same half that they give to everybody.
[INAUDIBLE]
But how does that work?
>> Well think about it. It's the reason that me and my sister don' t
look the same. We each got 50% of our DNA from our parents, but the
half she got from Mom, and the half I got from Mom aren't the same
halves. This happens because of two really important
processes called recombination and independent assortment in myosis.
>> Wait, what in what? Lauren, I think it's about time we zoomed out
and looked at the bigger picture of
how genomes and chromosomes are passed down from
parent to offspring. Up to this point, we've learned about what traits
are and how our DNA codes for them, both coding and noncoding,
how it can create and provide the foundation for these traits. But
we still don't even know how this material gets passed down. Sex.
>> I'm sorry, what?
>> Sex. That's, I know that's how you pass down genetic information.
>> this is true. Sex is the vehicle by which the hereditary
material is passed down from generation to generation. But. The question is do
any of you know what's going on at the genetic level? In this lesson,
we're going to learn how our genes
and chromosomes get passed down in interesting
patterns from generation to generation, making us
a unique mix of our parent's DNA.